Hồi công an với công bố dự thảo quy trình kỹ thuật Quốc gia về sinh chắc học sọng nói và bộ mắt,
có đây là thông tin cá nhân nhảy cảm cần còn lý chật chế theo pháp lượt bảo về dữ liệu.
Dự thảo quy định tuyển sọng nói lần đầu tư đủ sáo tuổi,
cấp nhật theo các nhóm tuổi mấy bố nguồn đến 20 năm, 20 năm đến bố nguy, bố mấy đề sảo nguy.
Công dân cảm kế sọng nói bình thường khi tuyển.
Kui trình cùng kiểm tra dễ tờ, sát thực, lập khu sơ và thu âm đến khi đặt yêu cầu.
Bối mông mắt, khuyến nghị đầu dữ thảo phạm vý cộ trường mấy đậu.
Anh sáng bảo đảm đường kính đồng tự bằng 20 năm đến 20 năm đồng kính mông mắt,
bảo kính và kính áp trong đề tuổi yêu chất lượng.
Chỉ các quan được bộ công an cho phép mới được tuyển,
sử lý và chia sẻ dữ liệu, bảo đảm hợp pháp, đúng mục đích và bảo mật.
Dữ liệu mông mắt chỉ chia sẻ khi chim câu sám định,
đồng bộ cơ sử dữ liệu quốc gia và các nhu cầu nghiệp vụ được phê duyệt.